welcome to the michaela peterson podcast
i was able to speak with the creator of
the subreddit wall street bets on my
podcast
jamie rogozinski before i get started
please remember to subscribe if you
enjoy these podcasts every sunday and
wednesday
wall street bets is a large online
community that yields what we now know
is a commanding presence in the world of
finance
i later found out that jamie isn't
involved in the subreddit anymore he's
no longer a moderator
and i did some digging into that
apparently he isn't popular in there
anymore
for according to people in the subreddit
selling out
i tried to get in touch with literally
anyone who would talk to me in that
subreddit to get their side of the story
however
nobody would talk to me so this is the
information i have
perhaps they're also concerned about
selling out or
busy with the court case that is
currently happening about this mess
wall street bets is recently famous for
its role in the shocking
sudden popularity of gamestop a stock
that skyrocketed to popularity and ended
up putting a number of wall street
hedge funds out of money mainly melvin
capital out of billions of dollars
we discussed that we also discussed
robin hood's decision to halt trading
when gamestop skyrocketed unexpectedly
robin hood stopped allowing people to
buy the stock
something that i think is completely
unacceptable from the bit i know about
the gamestop fiasco that took place
jaime's opinion differs though comment
what you think about this below
we also spoke about cryptocurrencies
selling the rights to jamie's story
and his book wall street bets new
sponsor from hover.com
hovers the number one site for domain
ownership in canada
but obviously they're not just for
canadians i own at least eight domains
i've bought every iteration of michaela
peterson that you fools can spell wrong
to direct to my website
it's not your fault my dad named me
after mikhail gorbachev and nobody knows
how to spell that
i cannot recommend buying domains enough
hover has a ton of
options for different endings too hovers
are jumping off point for a ton of
entrepreneurs and
having a domain name is super important
for that hover has over 300 domain name
extensions to choose from when building
your brand online
no matter what you want to build there's
a domain name waiting for it
you can end your website in blog or dot
diet or whatever instead of dot com if
you so choose
dot news etc i use hover for that reason
adding a dot something to your website
can be a better idea than a full on new
dot com
check them out at hover.com mp and get
10 discount with that referral link on
all new purchases
make a name for yourself with hover
hover hov h-o-v-e-r.com
mp also linked below enjoy the episode
let me know your thoughts on robin hood
wall street bets and who's in the right
or wrong here
and remember to subscribe
[Music]
do
damie rogozinski welcome to my podcast
hi thank you very much for having me
so can we just start off by you giving a
brief background
about who you are and what it is that
you do
so so my name is jamie rogozinski
uh i currently live in mexico i've been
living here for the past six years
i was also born here and i lived here
for the first 12 13 years of my life
i spent about 20 years in the u.s that's
where i went to school this went to high
school that's where i started my
uh career i'm i'm somewhat of an
entrepreneur
in the technology finance field and
that's currently what i do now
uh and i also am known for having
started wall street bets
uh this is back in 2012
uh like a community for people that
wanted to discuss any type of high-risk
trading
and it has been organically growing uh
quite a bit since that year and
obviously this past couple of weeks
it's made the news and also had
significant growth as well
so i wanted to have you on obviously to
discuss wall street bets
robin hood app gamestop
and just everything that's gone on in
the last couple of months for people who
aren't aware and i did some research so
that i don't sound like too much of a
[ __ ] but
can we start off with like what have we
heard in the news about
gamestop and wall street bets so what
happened there
so so like i said wall street bets is a
community of people that just
go in and they share ideas about trading
they take a really non-conventional
approach
usually people that go into the stock
market
take a a lower risk approach where they
make
valuations based off of discounted cash
flows and
projected sales etc with
in wall street bets they take a much
more laissez-faire approach
where they're making memes they're
making jokes they're making really
short-term
bets that are high risk and potentially
high return
uh and so what we saw this past couple
of weeks
is um uh you have you have hedge funds
which take which decided to take a trade
betting
against the price of a company called
gamestop uh this is called short selling
it's it's when they
basically profit if the price the prices
go down
and on the other side of this trade uh
wall street bets and a lot of amateur
traders
uh decided to take the other side of
that bed in other words they bought the
stock or they bought stock options
which because of the quantity of people
that were that were
involved they were actually able to push
the price up uh
and so here we have a situation where
you have hedge funds on one side
and then you have a lot of retail
traders on the other side
and these retail traders were out
muscling the big hedge funds
uh they they caused at least one hedge
fund melvin capital
that they needed to get bailed out by
their fellow funds they needed like two
or three billion dollars
uh in order to to cover their the cost
of this trade that they were losing that
the price of
gamestop went from something like 40
dollars
to 500 in a matter of days
uh this was the first time anything like
this has ever happened where
where retail traders have actually been
uh forced to be reckoned with
uh when when it's usually historically
been the hedge funds that are in charge
of
i guess moving the prices around i think
it got a lot of attention because
it's got a feel of david versus goliath
you know you have here
the little people that have been left
behind or the little people that don't
necessarily have much in effect they
collectively got together they got
organized and they were able to to
pull what's called a short squeeze
is there a reason that they chose
gamestop specifically
yes uh so as
as as silly as as wall street bets tends
to be
uh you know they make jokes they're
really crude
they they uh appear to be really
unsophisticated
by by people that first arrive there
basically
uh judging them by the type of content
that they're posting but
they a lot of people on wall street bets
are really knowledgeable and so
uh gamestop was was
chosen in part because you had a couple
of people a couple of high-profile
individuals that liked that company
right they say i like video games this
is my demographic
and these hedge funds are betting
against it i'm going to take the other
side of that trade so
so for starters it's a company they
liked but second of all
in order to pull the type of move that
they did
they they needed to have a lot of things
aligned so if they wanted to
to do something similar with a big
company like say apple
it would be much more difficult to do
and because of the size of the company
and because of what
what traders are currently doing with
that company
uh what what they did once again was
called a short squeeze it's a maneuver
that's that's
been around for a very long time
but it works really effectively when you
have a lot of people
that are betting against this stock what
ends up happening
when when a company is short this stock
they have to borrow shares from somebody
they sell those shares into the market
they hope for the price to go down
when the price goes down they repurchase
those those
shares at a smaller price they pocket
the difference and then they return the
shares to the original owner
what happens when the stock starts going
up is these
uh short sellers need to cover their
their loss they need to say okay it
looks like i was wrong about this and
they have to go out to the market and
have to buy this
the shares again even if it's at a loss
but
that purchasing forces them uh or forces
more money into the market and there's
more buying pressure which
which makes the stock price go go up
even further
so gamestop and specifically had a very
high percentage of of short flow that
meaning that a lot a lot a lot of people
were shorting it
uh and so this effect is magnified when
when when people start covering their
losses they end up
having to buy it more and so it's a lot
easier to force the hedge funds
to work against themselves in that sense
and so uh
so number one they like the company
number two it had a really high short
flow
so those those were the two main reasons
why it was um
done that way okay was this done as
was this done as some sort of protest or
was the main goal of this to make money
like i know there was occupy wall street
in 2010 i think
so did it have anything to do with like
that type of person or was it just
this is a way to make money you know i
think it turned into
i think it turned into what's looking
like a movement at this point but
um everyone on wall street bets is
hoping to make money right a lot of
people
go in there saying i'm gonna risk a lot
of money because the types of plays
especially since they use a lot of stock
options
uh those stock options are tend to be
really risky it's a kind of an all or
nothing type bet you know it's almost
like buying a lottery ticket
uh you're most likely going to lose but
if you
you're most likely not going to win the
lottery but but if you do win it's a lot
of money
um so so these guys on wall street bets
constantly looking for the next you know
the next opportunity
um i think the moment that they start
realizing that they're fighting against
these
these uh these hedge funds that are
shorted
uh it's it's a competitive field it's a
competitive you know
it's very sportsmanlike in fact a lot of
the banter really takes place like that
and we've seen oftentimes big big name
investors go against each other in that
similar fashion where you have like
uh bill ackman george soros
different high-profile individuals they
take different sides of the trade and
they kind of go at each other publicly
this was kind of started off as
something similar where they're saying
haha
you guys are going to lose money or
we're on this side you're on that side
and it starts kind of as a joke
and as soon as you start realizing that
they're costing these guys a lot of
money
then i think it resurfaces a lot of
these sentiments that were
uh bottled up since since occupy wall
street right and so these are people
that are that are possibly not involved
but that are observing from the outside
this is possibly people that are
involved with this you know you have a
lot of the
the demographics a lot of these guys are
uh and girls are young
they're they're millennials they're
generation z they saw
firsthand what it was like to to go
through the financial
crisis uh they saw their parents
struggle they
left college with that and no jobs and i
think that that those feelings of hey
now we've figured out a way to get their
attention right going out and
pitching tents and holding up signs was
uh not very effective we didn't get very
much done they just pretty much packed
their bags and went home with without
much of a
climax to that uh in turn this
this is saying all right well we can't
beat them we might as well join them
right we're going to hurt them
where where it hurts in their
pocketbooks and so
uh and so absolutely it turned into this
camaraderie where they're saying look
they're holding hands up and saying look
what we've done we've been able to knock
out this hedge fund
and i think that's also got a lot of
interest from outsiders so you had a lot
of people that are in politics or in
the entertainment business or uh
business moguls they all decided to
chime in and saying yes this is the
moment where the retail where
you know where the 99 are able to
recover the power that they've always
wanted
so doesn't this mean that technically if
you get
big groups of people organized on social
media this can just repeatedly happen
yeah i mean absolutely and i think
they're going to try to to
make it happen over and over again um
you know it's
it's a cop it's if you have a video on
youtube or tick-tock or whatever that
goes viral it's difficult to predict
what made that video go viral you know
uh
this particular stock that they all
decided to get around
you know it's it's who knows exactly
what all the factors were that made it
successful
uh but we've seen efforts of them trying
to do it again with a couple of other
businesses we saw them try it with i
think um amc the movie theaters and
blackberry uh so i have no doubt they'll
continue to try it
um but what's interesting about wall
street best if you take this this short
squeeze
uh saga out of the picture if you rewind
back a month or two
they've the the community is itself has
always been
has taken an attitude towards the stock
market as
uh is is a way to try to to make some
money and try to find these shortcuts
and try to find
what's called edge or to try to find uh
cheat codes is
something else that they call it where
they they identify a vulnerability
in the system and they try to exploit it
so in this particular case we saw a
short squeeze but we've seen
prior to that um individuals that are
also really really high profile
that didn't quite make as much noise as
it did this time around but it certainly
was
uh around for people that that follow
finance
where they exploited other weaknesses in
the system they were able to
uh a handful of people were able to get
what they called infinite leverage so
this means that they deposited
uh money into their account like two
three four five thousand dollars this is
back in november
2019 uh and they did these maneuvers
with these
with these stocks uh in stock options
where they took advantage of
uh the the leverage that they were
getting from their broker
and they and they identified a
a mistake that the broker was making
they weren't calculating
um the margin the collateral they were
they were making the calculations
correctly
uh when these guys were executing the
trade so they were able to repeat this
thing
and grow their buying power and their
account to up to a million dollars
so in other words without getting too
technical they deposit five thousand
dollars and they
click a lot of buttons right and they're
doing these things and then eventually
they see
on the bottom of their screen they say
buying power a million dollars and then
they can take that million dollars and
place it into a really high risk bet
and they can potentially lose all the
money potentially make a lot of money i
think some people made money some people
lost money with this case
uh but but that that event was symbolic
of what these guys are doing they're
looking for
you know they're looking for the cheat
in the game and and they're
uh they're also have that same mentality
of you can't beat them join them back in
2008
the banks were able to gamble with you
know everyone's money
on the global financial system uh
using these these fancy collateralized
debt obligations morbid gives back
securities the
credit default swaps blah blah blah and
then when they lost all their bets that
government came in there and
was able to to bail them out you know it
wasn't them that ended up losing any
money
so when these guys did this thing with
infinite margin it's the same thing it's
like
look it's not my money i just noticed
that there's a thing i can do and i can
click this enough times
if i lose the money it's going to be on
someone else's time i don't have a
million dollars to pay back you know
uh so and prior to that
were even more examples of of different
approaches so what i predict is going to
happen
is sure they're going to try and repeat
the short squeeze um
but but they're also going to continue
looking for these these vulnerabilities
in the system and try and exploit them
before that they're closed
okay but and and that's kind of what
isn't that kind of what wall street does
anyway
but in the opposite way absolutely it's
100
exactly what they do and that's what's
interesting about this is now
you know now the little guys can do it
too uh now they have all the tools to be
able to do it with
you know in 2008 if you wanted to buy if
you an individual
uh wanted to buy a mortgage-backed
security you're not able to do that you
have no idea where to even start
nowadays you open up your robinhood
account and you find an etf which
basically is a stock
and the stock is is uh uses
mortgage-backed security to calculate
its price
and then boom you're doing
mortgage-backed securities you know this
this
infinite money cheat code this infinite
leverage thing
was actually first used by banks in 2008
they used a different term for it was
called the reverse
buyback you know where they basically
lend a bank money
that that money uh you know that
overnight in that bank
uh to borrow the money give some
collateral to the loaner
then that loaner takes that collateral
and says wow i can get it alone based
off of this
this collateral and so then they can get
get alone themselves off that collateral
and they can do that over and over and
over
and they they did that uh uh basically
it's the same maneuver just
using different words so yeah what what
you're seeing right now is the retail
traders are figuring out a way to
to do the exact same thing banks were
doing back then and that's what's really
fascinating about this
yeah that's incredible uh okay so let's
go
what is this robin hood app let's start
there
so robin hood is a broker um so if you
want to buy stocks
you have to have a broker just like if
you want to have
uh a checkbook you need to have a
checking account with a bank right uh
and so you have uh you have a stock
exchange so you have a couple of stock
exchanges
in new york and that's where the actual
buying and selling of trades
of shares takes place and a broker is
the way that you connected to that
exchange for the most part
i'm simplifying a lot of this um and
robin hood is
is a a broker that is relatively new
it's
you know 2013-ish i want to say
uh is when they started and their
approach to offering uh
stock trading services to people was uh
very innovative they decided to make it
free usually if you want to buy stocks
it costs
a commission when i first bought stocks
in two thousand
six ish uh it cost me thirty dollars
to buy the stocks and another thirty
dollars to sell the stocks so it's if
you wanted to make a lot of moves it's
really expensive
um and robin had figured out a way to do
it for free
okay i didn't realize that was possible
i think buying stocks through my bank i
think it's ten dollars i don't think
it's 30
but i didn't realize you could manage to
do that for free so that's why that app
is so pop it's an app
right it is it's an app-based broker so
you know download it on your phone and
and the entire experience is on the
phone
uh and it's uh and it's really gamified
it's really
easy to use and i think that's another
component that's made it really popular
so number one it's free
and number two it's super easy you know
you go in there first of all it's got
these confetti animation makes you feel
good when you buy these things
um but they they started they started
offering stock options in 2018.
stock options are tricky they're
complicated they if
if i wanted to explain stock options to
someone i can use a few analogies to try
and get close to it but if you really
unders want to understand the nitty
gritties
uh of how they work it is very very com
people get their phds on
on you know the the way these things
work
um robin hood makes it like a complete
game you go in there and say
here i'll i'll give a real simple simple
explanation how stock options work
you have stocks right so this is like
apple or tesla whatever
you buy it goes up you make money if it
goes down you lose money
stock options allows you to do the same
thing you can you can basically place a
bet
that the stock is going to go up and the
stock is going to go down so so stocks
that are going to go up if you want to
bet that you buy something called a call
option if you want to bet that the stock
is going to go down you buy something
that's called a put
option um uh it gets more sophisticated
than that but
but the interface in robinhood you
basically say oh i want to buy tesla do
you want to do options sure i'll do
options because you can get more money
for what you pay
for uh and then you risk more and then
you kind of
scroll down you find one that you like
you click on it and then it asks you hey
are
you know you are you sure you want to
buy a call option for tesla do you think
the stock is going to go up or down
and you answer with a colored arrow you
know like the green arrow the up to
verify that you should
you're placing this type of bet
historically if you don't know
what a call option is it would give a
lot of people aneurysms thinking oh my
goodness these guys need to verify with
a green arrow that they think the
stock's going to go up
but that's what they've succeeded in
doing and so people don't even care to
understand how they work they just know
that you know that when the price goes
up it tends to go up for the most part
and when it goes down it tends to go
down for the most part
so it's it's made the experience really
easy really quickly you download it you
register you instantly fund the account
and
you know you start celebrating these
these game type
achievements every time that you make a
trade i'm sold
that sounds way easier than what i've
been fumbling around doing
uh so how how were they involved with
this
gamestop business well i mean
depending on how far back you want to go
they're involved
they start you know alongside this whole
democratization of the stock market in
the in the world of finance they've
played a big role
dating back to when they started um
they're the ones that that made it
possible for these retail traders to
come into the market with very little
knowledge very little money
very little uh pretty much anything time
to waste on these
uh registration processes and they
started building up a huge
a huge user base they have i don't know
how many tens of millions of users by
now
uh but but they're huge um without robin
hood
uh having revolutionized the the way
that the
stock brokers have to to do business
none of this would have happened but
none of this would have happened long
before
specifically with gamestop i mean they
played a role in that they're the
biggest broker
uh involved with this particular trade
you know they have
uh overwhelming number of accounts on
on the type of uh users that were
involved in these trades
they've incidentally robin hood has
forced the hand of brokers that have
been
around a lot longer to also have to
offer free trades as well because they
realize that they were getting
uh they were losing a lot of clients to
this type of business model and so a lot
of brokers now also offer
uh free trades or low commission trades
um uh but they you know it's still not
enough this robin hood
uh experience of being seamless
is is part of what's made this really
attractive so
thanks to robin hood everyone everyone
was involved in the market in the first
place and then thanks to robin hood
you know a lot of people were able to to
uh to pull off this trade but
specifically robin and having an active
role
um where they were they were advocating
for anything or taking any type of
uh posture on this it's you know they
were they were just the tool that that
was used by these people
didn't they stop trade weren't they in
the news for stopping trade for gamestop
and amc
they did and it's a really it's a really
interesting situation that happens right
so it happened with robin hood
and it happened with a whole bunch of
other brokers as well
um some some brokers were big brokers
like td ameritrade
this is another example of cracks in the
system that
needs to be uh evaluated so for from my
understanding what ends up happening
well first of all talk about the outrage
so so they stopped a lot you know
halfway through this
this entire uh saga is the prices are
going crazy
and volume people are trading these
stocks like crazy
um all of a sudden they stop allowing
people to purchase these shares for a
gamestop and a handful of these other
stocks and so everyone goes up in arms
and says wait a second
robin hood you're supposed to be the
good guy you're supposed to be the one
that's this
that's on our side how could you do that
you know of course
the moment that they restricted the the
trading of the shares naturally they
started dropping a lot so a lot of
people are losing money they get really
upset they
start some class action lawsuits um
other lawsuits that were started by the
i think the some prosecutor in new york
and everyone's upset right now this
results into these congressional
hearings that they're going to have
tomorrow and
they're calling in the ceo of robin hood
they're calling in a bunch of other
people
um and the the narrative there
is you just helped the big guy the big
guy was losing money
the little guy was winning and all of a
sudden you decide to stop allowing these
trading these shares and now the big
guy's able to recover some of his losses
the little guy lost money it's not fair
the system is rigged so that's the
narrative and i understand it and
and it's true to the extent that people
did lose money they did stop trading
they
they did stop uh you know they did have
an active role
in affecting the price and this this
short squeeze that was taking place what
actually happened was not a decision by
my understanding because it wasn't an
active decision by
robin hood or any of the other brokers
that had to that had to
restrict the trading it had to do with
the collateral requirements when you
guys
when when brokers buy stocks there's all
sorts of other stuff that takes place
behind the scenes and robin
specifically has its own um uh way of
doing things as well but basically when
you're buying and selling stocks you
have to wait a couple days for those
those stocks to reach your account and
for the money to reach the account of
the other person
it's uh you know what they're calling
the t plus two settlement dates
these are rules that have been
established from back in the day when in
new york you have to when you buy a
stock you had a physical piece of paper
certificate
you had to send it by horse or whatever
to the other people and
it took a few days and this is how long
it took takes to do things but nowadays
things are instant but nevertheless
the system is continued to uh to use
this it takes two days
to for the money to clear and so while
this money is being cleared people lend
each other money and they
they they give themselves uh uh what's
called margin
in order to uh release the funds when
you when you buy the stocks
you have sorry when you sell the stocks
you get your money right away instead of
having to wait for two days
that requires them to put up collateral
for that little transaction to take
place
and because the stock was going up so
high and because people were buying so
much of that stock and selling so much
of that stock
they ran out of that collateral that
they had to put up in order to keep
everything moving right
in other words uh they they were running
the risk of
uh running out of money becoming
insolvent i
that that hasn't been uh asserted yet
but it's it's
highly speculated that this was the case
and it was the case with most of the
brokers that had to stop
issuing these shares eventually robin
hood ended up getting a three point
something billion dollar
uh investment and that fixed the problem
right as soon as they had more money
uh they were able to to resume as as
normal now the big brokers that already
had that money didn't have this
issue right because either they had more
money or they themselves weren't so
uh involved with the buying and selling
of the shares and
and and so what happened robin hood
basically ran out of money so did the
other brokers
they had to restrict it to run the risk
uh to to avoid becoming insolvent to
you know avoid becoming bankrupt so uh
is does that excuse them i don't think
so
right but the whole system needs to be
reevaluated robin hood should have
foreseen this type of thing they should
have had
uh
you know processes in place to to to
handle this type of situation
but also the entire process of the
clearing houses and the you know t plus
two and the settlement
they have to re-evaluate um uh the way
this works so that we can get to the
20th or 21st century
where you have social media you have a
lot of volume you have a lot of
participants and you have these types of
things that can't happen
yeah because if this if this had
happened in the opposite direction with
people on
wall street making money then trade
would never be paused right
but then they wouldn't have had that
problem with running out of money
no i mean that's the accusation right
the accusation is
you did it because main street was was
winning and wall street was losing
um uh in effect that's kind of what
happened but it wasn't
because main street was winning and
wall street was losing it happened
because
they were unprepared for a
torrent for the stampede of people that
were just coming in and participating
and the prices moved
so incredibly high the volume
of of trees were was so incredibly high
it's never been seen before
um they they weren't ready for it so
it had they allowed um
[Music]
i mean i guess they might have had a lot
of choices but if they if they sat there
with their hands crossed and not stopped
the ability to keep trading
they would have had to close their doors
and say sorry we've become bankrupt
because the system
uh uh requires us to put up more money
and we don't have that money and
and so we're closing our doors think you
have a nice day
um and that would have been i think even
worse you know so they had to make a
defensive move did they make the best
move i
you know that's obviously up for debate
and i think we're going to hear a lot
more about that tomorrow should they
have prevented that
probably and so should have all the
brokers that had to restrict trading for
those shares
okay okay well that kind of explains
what's happened that's
kind of a wild story how has this like
affected you
for being the person who started wall
street bets like is there anyone
in wall street best that's in trouble
now or worried about being in trouble
for this
i you know so as far as i'm concerned
i've i've really enjoyed watching this
entire thing i'm no longer
actively moderating wall street bets
i've i've been away from that since
april of last year
uh it's you know so so i'm i'm watching
this on the sidelines really much
you know appreciating what's happening
this conversation that's being had today
i've i've felt the need uh to have for a
very long
time back since 20 right around the time
i started wall street business when i
started learning about all these
different tools that exist in the market
in the form of etfs and leveraged etfs
and inverse
synthetic exotic etfs and all sorts of
crazy things that you can
uh that you can do from your fingertips
that you can't really explain to the
average person
um that's that's not versed in finance
and i said this this this is crazy
there's a lot of weaknesses in the
system i thought
you know we were supposed to have
learned things from the 2008 crisis and
now here you have all these tools that
that are just these math formulas that
are that are somehow magically making
multiplying money and and things of that
nature so
these ever since i created wall street
bets i've been i've been wanting to have
this conversation i wrote a book about
this
uh that i published it even before the
the
pandemic outlining a lot of these
different things and predicting a lot of
these different things i didn't predict
it
the way that it was going to play out
but i predicted that with the quantity
of people that were coming into the
market and they were able to exploit
these different things and using social
media and things of that nature
uh uh it's it's you know i
i i i saw this coming and so now i'm
very much appreciating the conversation
that's had i'm hoping that
we get to see some some change by the
regulators and the legislators and
whoever else to
even the playing field to try and cover
up some of these vulnerabilities because
at the end of the day
um the financial system is if used
properly can be very productive for
society so
um so i've i've been enjoying this from
the sidelines obviously i've done some
interviews and things of that nature
um with regards to people on wall street
beds being in trouble
you know it's such a tricky thing if if
somebody had broken
the law uh overtly
um they would have already been in
trouble we would have known that by now
i saw some tweet by somebody that said
this this
situation with gamestop is the ideal or
the perfect
question on the final exam of a law
school you know
of law student because it's it's that
tricky uh you have
laws and regulations that prevent things
like stock manipulation and pumping and
dumping and things of that nature but
those definitions are very specific and
they and they're targeting very specific
actions mainly fraud if i
uh if i know something about a company
and i own those shares in that company
and i know that company's
stock isn't worth what it's worth or
it's going to go down and i decide to
lie about it
tell people hey this company's actually
got this revolutionary product and then
people get excited they buy
and then i offload my shares into that
uh into the market into the hands of
unwitting
individual investors then i'm committing
fraud i've lied to them and i've
profited from them or i've prevented my
losses because of them
pump and dumps kind of go towards
something similar um
but in this case we don't have people
that are lying we don't have people that
are trying to offload
the shares we have the opposite you have
people that are saying buy their shares
because we're gonna
you know we want to squeeze and we want
you know we like gamestop or we like
these companies
and because we're going to hurt the big
guys so so they're not lying right off
the bat they're not offloading their
shares onto the hands of our wedding
investors
they themselves are becoming the driving
force and so
that in itself isn't against the the
rules or the laws
you have a lot of personalities that are
on tv that do this all the time
jim cramer from cnbc you know he's got
this
uh program that's that's silly and he
goes oh you should buy this thing and he
makes all these these
sound effect noises and you know he's
giving his observations
uh there's disclosure rules you know if
you are purchasing
uh more than a certain percentage of the
company uh or any given company you are
supposed to disclose it
if you are being paid by a company to
to promote the stocks you're supposed to
disclose that but
once again you know these these hundreds
of thousands of people
you know they're they're uh
they're just buying the stock to buy the
stock um
i know that the sec is doing an
investigation they're looking into it
they're sifting through i don't know how
many hundreds of thousands of comments
it's very possible that they find some
people that
you know that fall into these criterias
where they make some statement possibly
in jester as a joke
uh or possibly being serious you know
and they'll be able to
to find those people and slap them on
the risk and find them for some
violation
um with regards to the moderators that
were
in charge of wall street bets i you know
it's i think it's a trickier situation
for them if they were
currently if they were if they were
involved in purchasing the the stock
options and they were themselves
were making money from it that's a
stickier situation because they can
control the narrative
on on the subreddit they can decide what
what goes and what doesn't go and they
can encourage
uh they can steer the direction a little
bit it's it is and that would count that
would count as something
done wrong i have no idea i don't know
um uh in once again if it was overtly
wrong we would have seen it by now
i don't know whether it is or isn't
i i think that if if there isn't
something wrong with it and and
i guess everyone's hoping that there's
nothing wrong with it my guess is that
they're going
to to to make some changes to prevent
this type of thing in the future because
uh was there fraud no was there
active manipulation not the way that
it's defined but was the stock doing
what it's supposed to do
well no it was doing some really crazy
things the stocks don't go from
40 a share or you know from a couple
billion dollars to 25 billion dollar
market cap overnight
um that's that's not how the stocks are
supposed to work other countries have
all sorts of controls in place that
prevent the stock from going up too much
if it's not justified
um you know it's arguments as to whether
that's
productive or not but but what we saw
with gamestop isn't what what the stock
market's meant to do the stock market
was created because i have a company and
i want to
to raise more funds so that i can
reinvest it into innovating new products
or whatever it is and
stimulating the economy creating jobs
and that's
that's why the stock market exists we've
been slowly getting away from that use
right now it looks nothing like
what it was meant to be used for but it
would be nice to have
people take a look at this and say okay
okay i think this got got away from us
we need to
to rein it back in a little bit let's
continue a lot of speculation
let's continue allow you know there's
there's there's a productive component
to speculation
there's even productive component to
short selling um but let's try and make
this more so that it
resembles the economy so so going
forward if it turns out nobody did
anything wrong
my guess is regulators and legislators
are going to come in and they're going
to try and
and re-evaluate and update some of the
the rules in order to make sure that the
stock market behaves
the way it's supposed to behave okay
and that'll end up affecting wall street
anyway because sometimes
stocks do shoot up right although will
they just avoid regulating those
somehow you know sometimes there's
there's good reasons for stocks
to shoot up right there's nothing wrong
with stocks shooting up if there's a
good reason for it
but there's something wrong wrong if the
entire system starts falling apart if
brokers have to stop lending
um uh allowing trades that's that's a
problem
so whatever led us to that point needs
to be addressed whether it's preventing
the stocks from going up that high i
don't think that's a practical solution
once again sometimes there's a reason
for that if you have a company that
announces the acquisition of another
company and they announced the actual
price of that acquisition
they pretty much set the new price and
if this company
was purchased for a really really really
big amount then the stocks the shares in
that price are going to go up by
the proportional amount perfectly
justified so there's
there's there's real cases to allowing
the prices to do whatever they want to
do and same thing when
the prices are going to go down um
you know is it going to affect uh uh
the ability for uh
these ripple of sorry these these ripple
consequences so you have these hedge
funds when
they're trying to cover their their
their
uh their losses with their shirt but you
know the more that the stock price goes
up
the more that they're on the hook for
for losing if they decide to close out
the bet
so they themselves have to start putting
up collateral money in case
uh the price keeps going up they can pay
off whatever that they owe
these funds ended up having to sell
stocks of other companies like
you know apple and facebook and i don't
know what other companies
in order to cover the collateral
obligations for this bet that they were
losing
the moment that they had to sell stocks
in facebook they started affecting the
facebook price because
they're getting rid of those shares um
nothing to do with evaluation of
facebook
that didn't make facebook very happy no
it didn't make a lot of companies really
happy so you have this
this crazy situation where where the
rest of the stock market's behaving
weird
that entire thing shouldn't happen you
know you shouldn't have the
the valuation of of uh individual
companies be negatively adversely
affected
because of what's happening with
gamestop
um so that's the type of thing that you
know that needs to be addressed so is it
going to affect
the way wall street works yeah maybe um
but hopefully in a good way that
prevents these types of crazy
situations from happening in the first
place
why did you end up so how big is wall
street best right now did it
shoot up after all the after probably
after all the news about it
it did yeah it you know it was
the vicinity of about two million users
um before that
and yeah it was a big community as it is
and now last i checked it was in
the vicinity of nine million users so it
was a very significant
uh increase in users it must be
difficult to moderate
i can't imagine a group with nine
million users that sounds like a mess
how come you ended up stepping away is
it just messy
it's that it's kind of a long story and
unfortunate as much as i'm dying to
share this story with you i'm not able
to anymore at this point i've i've
sold the rights to that story uh away
and so that that will be coming out in
the
uh in the near future what is it gonna
be
like netflix or a movie or something
yeah
that is that's weird how does that feel
that's got to be kind of absurd
it is a little bit absurd you know i was
approached by by several
writers and producers and directors and
studios and all these different things
so i got a kind of a crash course as to
how that works um
and uh yeah so i sold i sold the rights
to
uh to a production company that's going
to turn this into all they have i mean
they bought the rights to them
to the movies documentaries series
podcasts whatever you know
what they decide to do with it is um
up to them but i think the goal is to
make a movie out of this
cool they'll probably make it exciting
huh add in some death murder i hope so
do you know who you're going to be
played by i have no idea i got
i got asked that question a lot yeah i
really should know but no um
you know as long as it's a good it's a
good actor i'm i'm indifferent
yeah fair enough wow well that's that's
absurd um
okay switching topics slightly do you do
you have any knowledge about
bitcoin and what's happening with that i
just figure because you're
wall street best guy yeah you look
bitcoin is is fascinating i've i've been
very interested in it ever since you
know it's
came onto my radar it started off as
this academic
uh exercise right of a currency of a
digital currency that can be used as a
medium of exchange for goods and
services
in economics you need to have certain
properties and currencies
that they need to be it needs to be
scarce meaning
um it can't be infinite right like has
to you have to
run out of it something like gold for
example it's not they're not an infinite
amount
um it has to be
resilient right so physically resilient
to being destroyed so
it's difficult to burn or to to throw
bills of paper into the washing machine
and have it disappear
um gold itself it's it's it's resilient
physically speaking so you can't lose it
so you
take a couple of these properties for
for a currency and they say well let's
digitalize them what's what's to stop
something from being they created these
really fancy algorithms that use
um just these this blockchain encryption
things in order to make sure that
nobody can hack it uh and you have these
and and
you build rules into the system such
that you start creating more and more
coins similar to mining more and more
gold and finding more of it but slowly
uh as time goes on less less coins get
created and eventually they stop being
created
so it's a concept it was fabulous i said
well this is
you know this is really interesting my i
had reservations at the time i said well
i don't think
um governments would really allow this
but it's going to be an interesting
fight
because governments don't have a say on
this this is a decentralized
system meaning that there's no there's
no choke point right if you want to take
down a website
because it's violating some rules you go
after the servers where it's at and you
shut it down
right amazon web services for example is
kind of the backbone to
the majority of the internet if they
wanted to to knock that down that's
that's a centralized point
these um digital currencies they're they
don't have a centralized place they
exist on all computers at all times
um so you can't just they can go after
my physical computer but they're not
even going to put a dent on it because
this money exists everywhere
um so i figured it was going to be
interesting to see how it plays out and
we've seen
as the years go by a little bit of tug
and pull you know we had a situation
with
uh this company called uh silk road
many years ago which was kind of like an
ebay
use cryptocurrencies in order to to buy
and sell stuff and
because of because bitcoin is anonymous
and because it's difficult to trace
um uh it lent itself to a lot of
criminals a lot of people trying to use
it for buying drugs or
prostitution things of that nature and
silk road was kind of this hub where
people could buy
uh and sell these types of things and
you know the government went after them
they did shut them down effectively and
they did confiscate all sorts of money i
think the guy ended up in
the owner that sighted it up in jail um
and and so that was kind of the first
battle where you have government versus
this currency but the currency survived
it without any problem whatsoever
because the currency doesn't
you know you can't shut it down so i
think as the years go by
you start seeing um people warm up to
the idea government all of a sudden you
start seeing practical uses of it you
have companies
so you have countries that uh decide to
put
a capital freeze on on um
sending money away you know if they're
having issues with
with their own solvency and also bitcoin
is a good way to transfer your money out
of a country when your banks aren't
allowing it
um even if you're not in trouble if you
want to send money internationally it's
always been kind of a pain in the butt
uh cryptocurrencies really facilitate
that component of it so also you see
these practical uses and then you start
seeing it come mainstream you have a
couple of stores i i went to japan a
couple years ago and you see all the
signs on the stores you could actually
accept bitcoin in the stores
uh and now of course you're seeing you
know tesla is considering
um accepting payments for their cars you
see mastercard saying we're going to be
able to accept these payments you have
paypal
uh allowing you to buy cryptocurrency
through there and so
the adoption you can buy cryptocurrency
through paypal now
yeah they announced it at least at least
on my paypal
i haven't clicked it yet but there's a
button now that says i
i write about the announcement and then
i saw the button inside my paypal
yeah and uh but you don't even need
paypal anymore to do because now it's
really easy to buy it as it is it used
to be a lot more difficult and you have
to understand what this is and the key
and whatever
and now it's really easy uh so
so you know i think it's here to state
it's obviously
stood up the test of time and uh
governments are figuring out a way to
tax it which is perfectly fine as far as
i'm concerned that's good because that's
gonna
further legitimize it people can can
officially live
on bitcoin and then they can pay their
obligations to their local governments
and
continue to be good citizens that way
they're simply just using this new type
of currency so
it's it's fascinating having watched
i've really a huge fan of it i think
that it goes really well in line with
the
the democratization of finance this
thing is not controlled by anybody
you know there's a lot of complaints um
that have always been around from
central governments and central banks
and how the interest rate works and how
they're pumping the money not a fish
blah blah blah you know this thing is
not controlled by anybody this is just a
medium of exchange
and i think that because it's got a lot
of interest you know the price is going
up that
price is up over fifty 000 last i saw
but the the headlines have been the same
for the past decade right so i just i
was bored yesterday and i looked up
in google i typed in bitcoin surges
and then you can type in a thing that
you type in before 2005 it only gives
you results that are prior to 2005.
and i saw just tons of tons of articles
that showed the huge graph of the
bitcoin going up and it was up
200 per bitcoin and it's crazy and it's
going up because
you know whatever cyprus ended up doing
the thing of the bailout and all of a
sudden it goes up because
whatever you know and there's been
articles they're talking about the
surges
if you talk about this latest surge from
you know whatever it is
25 to 50 000 it doubled in price yeah
it's it's par for the course with
bitcoin it's you know we've seen it go
up a lot
i think it just feels different when it
goes up by twenty five thousand dollars
that that absolute amount
makes it feel a lot more uh substantial
so uh you know but that the price of
bitcoin has been going up for
pretty much since inception i feel like
once mastercard allows you to pay with
it it's going to
well that basically makes it legitimate
in most people's eyes i would think
it does and you know as far as i'm
concerned i think that
right now what you're seeing with
bitcoin as well as with a lot of these
other currencies
they're looking at a lot of people are
looking at it as a way to make money and
they're focusing on the price of
of uh of bitcoin is is this aura thing
because there's a lot of people who've
made a lot of money from this a lot a
lot of money a lot of millionaires and
some billionaires have been made from
bitcoin
but in order for it to fully be uh
adopted it's going to have to reach
reach the poise a point
of uh being stable you know if you want
to start really using bitcoin and start
accepting payments for these things that
that
uh exchange rate does kind of start
affecting your bottom line
or at least they have to adapt to the
way that they're
uh thinking about finance in order to
make up for it but you don't ask me
well what do you think of the euro right
oh the euro is really going off right
like you just well it's pretty much
always kind of sitting around that area
went up a little bit went down a little
bit
uh you figure out what it's worth when
you go and travel to europe and you need
to
to make that exchange um in order for it
to reach that currency status it's gonna
have to level out
and and until that day comes you're
going to see a lot of these speculators
that are using it
as a as as as an investment
as a way to make money as opposed to as
a way to use money
okay last question then i'll let you go
um what about ethereum and these other
coins
are they just people playing around or
are they going to be like bitcoin or
what
yeah i think there's a lot of things
that are taking place uh
do you have a lot of coins these alt
um that are trying that saw what
happened with bitcoin and they're hoping
to be the next one
like man i really should have bought
bitcoin when it was 10 bucks each you
know i'd be
worth billions of dollars by now uh but
whatever that
that train is left so let's go ahead and
pick a different coin and let's do the
same thing so that we become a
millionaire so i think you have a little
bit of that
uh gold rush feel to these digital
currencies
um but but they all have um
they're all well a lot of them are
unique things that they can be grouped
ethereum and i'm not a super expert on
crypto so
if you have a lot of crypto listeners
they'll probably um
be screaming at their their computer or
their phone but
you know ethereum has these coins have
these algorithms built into it so that
when i
make a transaction with you um
the system is built such that that it
verifies that transaction i can't just
because i'm really good with computers
write a bunch of zeros and ones and say
oh i sent you a coin and it doesn't
really exist right i can't send you a
false coin
but computers have to work on these math
problems and they need to
to all agree that that this token took
pl you know that this exchange took
place
um these these uh
the mechanics of that can sometimes be
really cumbersome they can they can take
a long time in order to do that so if i
were to send you bitcoin
um depending on how much and a
bunch of different variables it can take
a while before that
um uh you know before that that
that bitcoin is fair that transaction is
verified and you can officially
then use that coin to spend it somewhere
else ethereum solves some of these
problems they're a lot more efficient so
if i wanted to pay you using ethereum
uh it'll do it faster and so you don't
have to wait that same amount of time i
think that there's also rules
regarding the the growth so i mentioned
earlier that the scarcity component of
currencies bitcoin has a predefined path
that you know there's at the beginning a
lot of bitcoins are being created
automatically
you know by this algorithm and
eventually there's going to be no more
bitcoins
right there's going to be a point where
you can't create new ones you can only
treat the ones that currently exist
those rules of scarcity are also
somewhat different with ethereum and
that that goes the same for
a lot of these other altcoins some of
them are are capped since the beginning
that where they say there's only
you know 100 million of these coins and
that's we're never going to have more
other ones they say well you know we're
going to be able to go on forever
or another ones that kind of adjust
based off of how much volume there is
and
um they tweak the algorithm to the rules
a little bit and
and try to to meet different needs so i
ethereum i would put in a different
category as
a lot of the other um altcoins
just in that the fact that they also
wanted to be a bitcoin with a lot of the
bitcoin problems
resolved gotcha okay thank you very much
uh where can people find you online
uh so you can find me on probably the
easiest is wall street
bets on all three words spelled out on
twitter
and then on that profile i have links to
my other social media accounts
perfect thank you very much thank you
very much for having me it was fun
that was fun i learned a lot that was
good
i'm glad
[Music]
you